hello everyone this is a quick overview
of the different sections of the
platform and how they work together
first of all right here you are seeing
the edu dot T - bio info website that is
where you have courses so you can click
on the courses right here and you will
see a number of courses and of course we
mentioned today introduction to
bioinformatics transcriptomics one
transcriptomics two and transcriptomics
three now take these courses you will
have to login so you can use your the
same email id so use one email ID for
your registration and then generate a
new password
you can also login using your social
media accounts but then you have to
update your email to match now the
second place is this server the t - bio
info website and that is where you
process data so again here you will
receive an email with your account
access information there will be your
email address and we will give you a
password and later on you can change
your password if you don't want anyone
to have access to so what do you see
here you will see different sections and
within sections you will see a this top
part where you can upload data different
types of data and build the pipeline so
if you don't have data you cannot upload
the pipeline upload anything to the
pipeline you cannot make a pipeline you
cannot run anything so you cannot just
learn here by looking at things you have
to have a data set where are the data
sets so the data sets are in several
places the first place is inside the
courses so as you go through the courses
you will be given a data set for example
I can take this course and you can see I
have to again login okay I'm logging in
I'm going to be able to access the
course and inside the course
let's go to simple example of RNA seek
analysis okay here's an example you see
breast cancer education one dot svl what
is an SPL file an SPL file looks like
this an STL file essentially contains
links to data that is uploaded on the
server so size service is the server
that you see over here this is size
server and you have multiple samples so
now that I went over here and I
downloaded this data set you can go back
over here and I can upload some data now
when you use svl files these are files
that are already on the server you do
not use add files you use URL bulk
upload so I can quick right here click
right here samples svl and then you can
see a number of different files and then
I can start creating my pipeline how
does this relate back to this well first
of all here you see a video of how to
create a pipeline and then it tells you
step by step what to do how to upload
your data how to define your parameters
how to create groups all the things that
I just showed you it will be right here
and then you will be guided on how to
create that first pipeline after you've
done the pipeline you will also be
looking at the different parameters
within individual buttons and finally
you will see this screen which is under
my pipelines and it's right here okay
now you will also see the output and
this is what the output looks like for
gene expression data set so these are
samples that you just saw and these are
gene names gene IDs in ensembl gene
structure so what are these things if
you remember within our file we have
these names
and they have 1 & 2 1 & 2 1 & 2 because
they're pair and so you can see here
that these are already renamed to pair
end so I hope this quick overview
simplifies things a little bit better
for you in terms of using the two
separate links that we gave you
edu dot t - bio info and server dot T -
biotech info